foreign
[Music]
I would just love to start with you at
the very beginning I mean so I'm
wondering for you growing up as a child
were you aware of Marilyn even as like
an icon as an image
uh what we actually did have some
American films playing on TV all the
time I did grow up just watching you
know
romantic comedies Richard Gere and Tom
Cruise and Julia Roberts and all of
these wonderful movies and
um
and I remember asking my mom not long
ago when we premiered the movie in
Venice if she remembered movies of you
know Maryland on TV and she was like
absolutely yes they were you know I I
guess I just I must have seen them but I
didn't recognize at the time that that
was Maryland so I wasn't very much aware
of her until later on yeah
well I always think you know as a Critic
we get frequent Maryland biography
pictures and I always think of it as
like this real challenge for an actor
you know it's like this is a face that
we in the audience know so well this is
a person we know so well
and what I really like about the way you
choose to play Marilyn is that like you
clearly have like wonderful makeup team
wonderful hair team but you chose to
focus I believe uh not unlike any
Prosthetics there's no Prosthetics here
but more like the interior Spirit of
Maryland and I'd love to hear more about
that like what is the inner Spirit of
Maryland that you really want to focus
on
um
well first of all I think it's always
important to remind people that it's not
a biopic it's based on the book because
Marilyn was not just this she was many
other things and she was also wonderful
in many other ways this is also an
interpretation of all these photographic
memory that we have of her and we're
reinterpreting and giving a different
meaning to all these images that we've
seen throughout our entire lives that we
have a history or a story attached to
those images and we're kind of like
showing a different side of that because
sadly
this is also a part of what she went
through and that hasn't been shown and
this is why to your point I was focused
on not the image that we're familiar
with which is the on-screen character
that we're used to seeing but Norma Jean
the woman who lived through a horrible
trauma during childhood and then had to
go about life the best way she could so
that was I think my my focus I wanted to
peel all those layers of this character
that
of course I had so much material to look
at and do research and movies to watch
and and audio recordings and interviews
and you know the book and everything you
can imagine but
who was Norma Jean who was her before
all of that happened
and how was she feeling when that was
happening because sometimes especially
in this industry this
there are things that are happening to
you that you just put in that position
and you have to keep delivering and
showing up because it's what's supposed
to you know it was expected and you
don't really have time to process it and
you just keep going with it until you
can't handle it anymore and you break
you know you break so for me
the movie's not literal or chronological
it's it's not a biopic
but the emotional truth had to be there
in order to care for this person that we
haven't actually met
so that was that's what I was really
interested in and also
just focusing on Maryland and
Recreations and what we've seen it would
have been a very restrictive
you know thing for me to do
um so I thought it was only fair that I
would bring you know who I thought she
was or was going through emotionally
um and give her that chance to be a more
dimensional person not just one thing
does that make sense no it makes a ton
and I love that you're talking about
this is almost like sort of playing two
characters
we all have that we all have a private
person and a public person when you take
someone like Marilyn
you know as an example of course that is
is a you know
magnified you know it's uh it's there is
no one bigger than her so
um it it is a struggle because you're on
the spotlight and that public person
becomes
you know in her case probably her armor
and at the same time her prison because
she couldn't get
away from it
um yeah I mean like people who knew her
in person have sort of said that
when she wanted to just be Norma Jean
she could almost turn a light off and
become invisible and then when she
wanted to be Maryland it was like she
could turn a light on from within you
know like I I think she she was pretty
aware of that I think for her that the
the line was pretty clear she knew she
was not mariling I
for Norma
Maryland was some someone that she could
not live up to like she didn't recognize
what people saw in Maryland she knew
that that was not her she talks about
Marilyn always as a third person
um
yeah yeah well I mean there's a scene in
this movie that I really love that kind
of brings together so many layers and I
think asks so much of you and I would
love to hear more about it which is you
know it's early in this film there's an
early audition scene very early on black
and white We're auditioning you know to
play the part of Nell and it's one of my
favorite scenes it's wonderful I want to
hear everything about it but like you
you come in you know you're Norma Jean
you're not Maryland to anybody in that
room yet you're on the process of
becoming a person who's respected you
know hopefully by the men in the
industry and so those two things are
already happening in the character and
then you're putting on this other
character of Nell this like dark you
know woman who's not taking care of the
kids in her care and then you're also
adding in I feel like in that scene
elements of her own mother in her own
experience and this scene is just so
stacked with meaning and you playing it
have to do it in this you know really
long take where you work out to tears
I just want to hear everything about
that scene to be honest because I think
it's such a great Showcase of your
acting thank you
um
you know I watch the movie sometimes and
I don't know how I did some things I
really don't and there are moments that
I really cannot explain the process
because I don't think it was a conscious
thing I'm not a I'm not an actor that
goes to set or
tells the director in advance I'm going
to do this and I'm going to do it this
way so everyone knows I just I'm just
there and it happens and every take is
different because I try different things
so
I think that
you know at some point all of that
research that we did for so long and all
the work
just
comes out in ways that you know they
were it was there inside of me and you
know they manifest or something
um but that scene is it is beautiful
because at that point
she's still not Marilyn I think that at
the beginning also Norma
she was ambitious she wanted to have
this career she wanted this to happen
for her and then this character got
created and pretty soon it got out of
hands and she lost control of it but at
that point she's still doesn't really
know who she is or supposed to be and
she was really nervous she was very
insecure and she was not being taken
seriously clearly and at the time you
know also like you said she just saw her
mother for the first time and
you know it's a very strong
um scene because you do see the layers
of
Anna playing Norma playing Marilyn
playing a character so it is it is
tricky but then when she looks to the
side yeah
and all the heads turn
you feel and you can see how commanding
and how magnetic she was and how good of
an actress she was and that was probably
one of the first and few dramatic roles
that she had the chance to play
um
he was it was a it was a lot of fun and
then unfortunately at the end of the
scene you realize that
all of that was for nothing and they
were just looking at her ass
what's fascinating I think if I'm if I'm
hearing correctly about how you build
your process is that
we you know people who study of America
and people who see this movie know that
she worked you know very much by like
digging into like personal trauma she
was training with Strasbourg to figure
out how to work with her own pain from
the inside but it sounds like you're
playing an actress who worked in one way
when you work in a very different way
yourself
is that accurate is sorry oh that yeah
that um that you don't like to work the
way that Marilyn does I'm guessing by
summoning your own pain and Trauma
um
I mean I think
there was so much for me to
um there was so much much for me to do
and feel on places to go in this movie I
think I definitely
um used
a lot of the things I haven't had the
chance before
to use before you know to use of myself
um and I was very surprised about it
because when I thought of Maryland at
the beginning I was like what do I
well I do not have anything in common
with this person and I'm Cuban she's
American differing era different time
different you know upbringings
everything but to my surprise I I
actually quite understood pretty quickly
um
her situation
um
so I I guess I did I am I don't think I
am a method actor I don't stay in
character definitely not in this one
um
because it was uh it was just really
really
immersive and demanding and intense and
that kind of like you know getting out
of it was important
um
but I think I did I did use some of my
it's all I mean it's
um
it's all me there I mean it's pretty
obvious that I gave all I had I
there was there's nothing left that was
it
um so yeah
I mean another thing I'd really love to
talk about you know
you were explaining I think so so
wonderfully how this isn't like a
biographical picture and yet we have
these tiny touchstones of things we sort
of know or different marriages and you
highlight some stuff within those
marriages very quickly and so simply and
the scene that really pops out for me is
when you have just married DiMaggio and
you're walking through his very loud
house and I had never really thought
about how that marriage was for her day
to day until you're you know you just
show how uncomfortable she is surrounded
by people who feel so free to talk and
it made me realize I heard that one of
the things that Andrew Dominic did when
you were coming up with this character
and how to play her is he took an
emotion off the table for you that you
weren't allowed to show yeah and it was
anger yeah
well I think when you know
um
I do think that she's just failed for
the most part so removed from connection
that is something that she wasn't
familiar with when you're a child and
you're told that everything bad that
happened was your fault that you're not
wanted that you know your father left
because of you and you feel that kind of
rejection
um
you
will see live and and navigate
situations in a completely different way
and see everything through that lens and
she spent her entire life trying to
not feel rejected again trying to get
that love from people and therefore
anger or rage was not something that she
could afford because that would push
people away and that's why she had no
boundaries and that's why people kept
taking and taking and taking and taken
from her and until she had nothing left
and that scene is amazing because you
can see this relationship with these two
people could not be more farther apart
they're like from different planets they
don't speak the same language she really
does not know how to interact in a
normal
uh
you know like a daily routine family
life she she has no idea how to do that
and she's trying to communicate that to
him as well and he talks about baseball
you know or boxing or I don't know what
you know like completely out of touch
and and intimacy and and that's why you
realize that she never was able to get
that again there was no real intimacy
there she was just
needing and yearning for company but no
in depth she could not really connect
with people or the other way around
people could not connect with who was in
Maryland
I love that and we're going to open it
up for audience questions in just a
second but before we do I want to ask
you know you touched on how this was so
important to kind of
trigger our memories of famous images
we've seen of her and I mean
hey it seems like you had more costume
changes in this movie than I have seen
in almost any movie but I'm wondering
how did that work for you inside of a
scene to think like I'm capturing this
Photograph did you also have to stay
aware of oh if I tilt my head this way
or if I cross my legs oh my gosh yes it
will remind people what this is oh yes
Andrew
um this is one of the you know this is
the visual idea for the film Andrew
created this photographic Bible with the
entire movie scene by scene in pictures
and images that we've seen
you know our entire lives and every
scene it's a picture so we would print
the pictures uh the size of the Monitor
and put it next to the Monitor and we
would have to start the scene or end the
scene in the same position frame color
lens everything as the real picture
the black and white and the color is not
a random decision is if the picture was
black and white the scene is black and
white is the picture is color the scene
is color
um so you get the audience into it and
you're making them see this familiar
image
that they have in the back of their mind
and and just like making it feel like it
becomes alive
um
what was the question oh just about that
like because I'm imagining having yes
hold your limbs so yes so we have to be
like in the position of like for example
this picture of this moment of Bobby and
and myself in the window when they're
reading the poem we've seen this picture
and we always think oh this is so
beautiful so romantic
and is not at all like that you know so
it was very very specific and Andrew was
very you know meticulous about it and
and and the Wardrobe we we did exact
replicas of all the dresses and the
makeup the you know the makeup and hair
work in this movie is so wonderful like
something was wrong with that and you're
off you can't just keep you can watch it
anymore you could you can't you don't
buy it so I was so lucky to have these
people
so you know everyone on the same page
everyone with the same love and respect
and so passionate for the project and
you know it was it was incredible and
doing these Recreations was
pretty surreal because you've been
seeing these movies your entire life and
you're there recreating seven year age
or diamonds or you know any any of that
and it's just like
uh mind-blowing that you're kind of like
doing exactly the same it's it was
beautiful it was a great part of the the
work that that we did yeah rehearsing
all of that and doing the same thing
I heard that one of her secrets to get
that glow was she would wipe vaseline on
her face
I don't know if that's true
probably I believe that I think I've put
that vaseline on my face at some point
too yeah the old tricks they work
we're gonna go throw it out to audience
questions who is first microphone but
how much you'll start here
find out where she would oh sorry in
your research did you find out where she
learned I mean from all the reading that
she did of those books it's not
mentioned in the film at all like those
days
and all of those where she read all of
those
if she read those books no where like in
her what part of her life oh I think
um
he loved reading it's my understanding
and she was very curious and one of her
the reasons why she was insecure is
because she really didn't have great
education growing up so she compensated
reading a lot and getting herself
dialect coaches to speak better she used
to stammer and she so she wanted to
sound and and and be prepared at all
times and and know as much as she could
so I I do know that she started reading
very early on and and then later when
she went to New York for the actor
studio and all of that so I'm I'm
guessing she read all over the
did you have to capture her dialect
changes as she's changing as her voice
is evolving I mean I didn't you know
when you see her movies like you can see
the different works that different
dialect coaches did with her like from
one movie to the other one the jump in
the accent and you know it's really
crazy and you know sometimes in one of
the movies she
talks every word like that and it's like
she accentuates every war and that was
that coach that she had at the time and
then she had different you know
um but no I had enough with focusing on
just one accent
oh yeah I saw a question right here
hi there so I want to say that was one
of the most human and authentic
portrayals I've ever seen on the screen
yeah
um and I wanted to know
thank you
how things like the awareness on mental
health and me too informed how you
played this character
oh my gosh I think you know
um
this story was very very personal to
Andrew I think childhood trauma was what
Drew him into you know falling in love
with this project so Andrew and I talked
a lot about it and
fortunately these things
you know are being spoken about at this
point which she didn't have that
uh privilege at the time and she felt
very lonely
so you know it's um
I I am lucky that I'm much more aware of
mental health and Trauma and what it is
like to deal with
um
a traumatic childhood and parents and
problems like that and you know it was
just um
part of the research but
yeah does that answer your your question
okay
I think I think our time for Omar she's
very excited and I'm sorry to send the
microphone all the way back
she can't even wait for the mic
thanks
I'm so excited about this film I thought
I was gonna hate it I'm so sorry I was
told that's awful it's terrible you know
kind of the Maryland thing you know
everybody hates her and I had actually
had my my ex-husband's mom told me she
was terrible and they hated her at
school and so I had these weird things
in my head but what how I feel about
this film is what you're talking about
that the real subject is the mental
illness and being a child and not being
aware of what to do when you become an
adult because you're always alone all
the time and to be like you said to be
aware of learning how to be with people
and to be in a group and be part of a
family
and I I think that is what will get
everyday people to come watch this movie
and that's what I'm really excited about
do you feel that way too thank you I do
I do yes it's not just Marilyn Monroe
exactly I think for the most part yeah
thank you I think for the most part this
is a movie about you know this woman and
that's why I was able to connect with
her because I have been
there in in many of you know I can I can
relate and I can empathize with this
idea I I did not have I had wonderful
parents but I had friends that didn't I
remember this
I know what it feels like and I also my
it's my job to imagine what it is like
and to put feelings you know to give
that
turn it make it real and
um I think for the most part this movie
is about her the woman that was dealing
with this and that herself
you know
she wanted to be a mom as well but
her only reference was not good at all
so she just also struggled with that
deep desire of being a mother and and
loving and she just she was terrified of
not
being able to
um so yeah I I I I I think I think maybe
the the perception of the movie is that
it is another film oh another movie
about Marilyn Monroe but I I feel like
it is not at all that and it goes way
deeper and and into is more interested
in the human you know than than the the
actress
I think that is a lovely note actually
to wrap up so I want to say first thank
you Anna for being here uh thank you
everyone here for coming please tell
people to come see blonde tell them to
see this amazing performance thank you
foreign
[Music]